Let me just remind you where we have been through,...
...what we've been through.
My dad, like many of your folks who got relatives here,...
...many of you whose relatives did the same thing.
Who are, you're here, your relatives probably are not.
I think it is, in a sense, it's a...
Let there be a stable Iran.
Iran that is capable of rejecting Iranian influence.
I mean Iraq.
Our people done a really good job of hauling in a lot of the key operators.
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed, Abu Zubaydah, Ramzi al-Shibh, whatever the guy's name was.
Thanks for coming, be seated.
Thanks for coming, welcome to the White House.
Thanks for coming.
If it feels good, do it.
If you got a problem, blame somebody else.
You may recall we went through a park in Botswana.
Panama City, Panama.
What you probably wanna know is the three words I'm not gonna tell you.
I'm not going to tell you.
That's five words.
You'll be able to see a technology,...
...a technology that will enable you to converse with somebody on long distance...
...and it seems like the person is right there in the room with you.
Yeah, I think tide turning, I see as I remembered, I was raised in the desert...
...but tide's kinda, it's easy to see a tide turn.
Did I say those words?
The left hand now knows what the right hand is doing.
In the streets of major cities,...